*Battle music playing
My fellow bros, my fellow brethren, my fellow comrades
the time has come for us to fight back
no more
will we become oppressed by mainstream
media!
No more
will I take this online abuse
and hatred!
No more
will I say "I'm sorry, I messed up Okaay?
And you know why?
I'm number one. I'm number one
No more lame boxing matches
I challenge T-series into a saber fight like real men
I'm throwing my glove at you T-Series
Fight me
IRL to the death. No boxing glove and helmets
I'm talking about to the death here
If they won't accept my sword challenge
then the only thing we can do is fight fire
with fire
Smash
Subscribe
Smash-sub-scribe
Smash Subscribe!
SMASH SUBSCRIBE!
SMASH-SUB-SCRIBE 激怒
What are we gonna do?!
'smash subscribe'
That's right
*Outro Music (Jake is too fast, I can't write down the lyrics lol)